Jean-Luc madeleck bonjour Alors Patrice
téléspectateurs de TV Phil vous connaît
très bien parce qu'on fait au centre de
la excellente émission grâce à vous
parce que c'est vous qui racontez des
beaucoup de choses sur l'art de la table
qui s'appelle de bouche-à-oreille et
puis les habitants des Yvelines vous
connaissent aussi parce que voilà vous
êtes le Patron de ce lieu le restaurant
de La Commanderie des Templiers
Élancourt alors on va parler un petit
peu de ça on va faire un peu plus
connaissance avec vous si vous le voulez
bien alors ça fait combien 20 ans 20 ans
20 ans au mois de juin dernier nous
sommes arrivés ici en juin 1981 donc
nous avons fêté nos 20 ans en juin 2011
dans ce restaurant qui s'appelle les
Templiers parce qu'effectivement est
situé dans la commanderie des Templiers
de la ville-dieu à Élancourt et sachez
Patrice que ce bâtiment est le plus
ancien bâtiment de la ville nouvelle de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines alors voilà 20
ans comment ça évoluer ce lieu depuis 20
ans écoutez le restaurant grâce à Dieu a
bien évolué il est situé dans cette
commanderie dont l'objectif depuis la
fin des années 70 était d'être un centre
culturel et artistique alors il se
trouve que ce lieu réexiste je dirais
parce que l'ensemble des activités
culturelles ont été fermées pendant près
de 10 ans vous savez probablement que
cette ville nouvelle de 50 ans en
Yvelines fut longtemps organisé en un
établissement public d'aménagement et un
syndicat d'agglomération nouvelle bon le
pad Saint-Quentin a disparu le SAN aussi
et c'est maintenant donc une communauté
d'agglomération c'est la comité
d'agglomération qui est propriétaire de
cette bâtisse extraordinaire et il se
trouve que pour des raisons de budget et
de mise en place de mise en oeuvre des
programmes ce lieu a été fermé pendant
10 ans il est sur sa partie culturelle
en travaux depuis maintenant deux ans et
enfin les travaux vont se terminer
probablement à 2012 et nous allons
renouer avec les activités culturelles
et il y a quand même des expositions il
y a des artistes en résidence les
expositions ont repris depuis un an
maintenant dans le bâtiment des gardes
qui est le bâtiment situé à l'entrée de
la bâtisse de la Commanderie et puis la
chapelle et le bâtiment qu'on appelle le
bâtiment de Bièvre sont en rénovation la
chapelle avait eu quelques soucis de
pierre de voûte etc donc la chapelle
d'ailleurs en ce moment est entièrement
abrité derrière un échafaudage et les
travaux devraient se terminer très très
vite et puis nous allons accueillir ici
dans la Commanderie d'autres activités
nouvelles à partir de mi 2012 voilà mais
le restaurant Le restaurant lui il a
continué son activité bon au malin
pendant pendant toutes ces années et
c'est vrai qu'il s'est fait enfin on a
réussi finalement à faire une réputation
pour le restaurant en lui-même et nous
avons un parking de bonne capacités qui
permet à nos clients ce qui nous
connaissent comme ceux qui nous
découvrent
ça fait 20 ans juste avant vous étiez
pas exactement dans la dans la
restauration vous êtes en fait
je je suis né en 1953 donc ça vous
laisse le calcul assez facile je vais
avoir 58 ans à la fin de l'année et donc
avec mon épouse Annie nous avions 38 ans
lorsque nous avons pris cette affaire et
euh
non mais en même temps
et alors Annie et moi avons des
activités très différentes avant Annie
était fonctionnaire et moi j'ai passé 10
ans dans un groupe qui s'appelle Forest
Hill le dernier la Courbevoie alors j'ai
effectivement dirigé d'abord un hôtel
pour le groupe forestier à Bougival qui
est devenu d'ailleurs maintenant ensuite
j'ai pris
sous la direction du président Michel
Corbières puissant du groupe forestier
la responsabilité du développement de
produits complètement nouveau en France
puisque j'ai développé
couvert urbain et donc c'est parce que
nous avions construit d'abord à Lille à
Dijon et à Nîmes ont débouché sur la
programmation et ensuite la construction
de l'Aquaboulevard qui jusqu'à
maintenant d'ailleurs est le plus grand
site de loisirs couvert
urbain en Europe avec un monde alors oui
c'était extérieur
en pleine période de l'essor en fait du
loisir urbain vous savez que à partir
des années 80
il y a eu un changement de majorité ça
vous a pas échappé dans notre pays
et voilà et que à l'intérieur de la
politique qui était dégagée par la
nouvelle majorité il y avait une place
prépondérante donnée au temps libre
voilà il y avait un ministre du temps
libre il y avait un ministre sur Henri
Monsieur Henri qui était l'ancien patron
de la fédération de l'éducation
nationale Premier ministre du temps le
seul d'ailleurs
on est passé au travail ce qui est
intéressant dans cette affaire c'est que
finalement le fait de prendre une
politique pour dégager du temps pour les
gens aller amener se faire cuire les
avait plus de loisirs c'est à cette
époque là qu'on a lancé tous ces projets
extraordinaires dont
mirapolises mais aussi à l'époque Disney
et l'Aquaboulevard un autre projet qui a
vu le jour et qui en même temps que nous
à la boulevard à l'époque c'était le
Futuroscope de Poitiers mais tous ces
parcs étaient des parcs de loisirs qui
étaient à l'extérieur
c'était vraiment le parc de loisirs à
l'intérieur de la ville couvert parc
aquatique mais aussi à l'époque tennis
des restaurants des galeries voilà un
absolument extraordinaire cinéma
qui s'est développé et donc je me suis
occupé avec Michel Corbières le
président
de la programmation puis du suivi du
chantier parce que le chantier a duré
près de deux ans puis du lancement de ce
programme pour vous donner un ordre
d'idée le premier jour d'ouverture de la
boulevard de Paris nous avons accueilli
25000 personnes ça vous donne un ordre
d'idée de grandeur de ce que c'était
alors alors
femme il y a quelques instants c'est un
peu elle qui vous a poussé à venir ici
elle m'a poussé elle m'a tiré en dehors
en réalité mon chien Patrice il se
trouve que l'Aquaboulevard et le groupe
forestier me prenait beaucoup beaucoup
de temps ce que j'avais aussi à
m'occuper des autres affaires en
province et donc allez j'étais 100% de
mon temps ou quasiment là que boulevard
vous pensez bien que quand on est en
couple avec deux enfants à un moment
donné votre femme vous dites donc chérie
alors du coup nous avons pris la
décision moi de quitter la queue
boulevard et elle de quitter la Caisse
des dépôts et figurez-vous que nous nous
sommes mariés à 20 ans à l'époque mon
chien Patrice on vivait pas à la colle
comme c'est le cas aujourd'hui non non
non
se marier et d'ailleurs je n'imaginais
même pas demandé au papa d'amis si je
pouvais vivre avec sa fille il fallait
passer par le mariage et je me réjouis
nous sommes mariés avec Annie depuis
près de 38 ans et ça se passe très bien
une sorte d'exploit aujourd'hui
il y a plein plein de gens qui restent
mariés et c'est très bien comme ça et
puis du coup elle m'a dit bon ben voilà
moto à gauche voilà et donc
avant l'Aquaboulevard et avant la
période forestile qui a duré 10 ans
j'avais eu un parcours de restaurant et
d'hôtellerie j'avais fait l'école de la
rue Ferrandi très connu maintenant mais
à l'époque les les formations a fait on
mixte sale et cuisine et donc j'ai roulé
ma bosse dans des affaires comme les
palaces à Deauville comme le pied de
cochon
de l'armée maison mythique et à l'époque
les le pied de cochon aux Halles c'était
vraiment la brasserie ouverte 24 heures
sur 24 et il y avait encore les
pavillons Baltard nous sommes en 1974 et
donc les pavillons Voltaire existaient
toujours c'était bouchés qui étaient là
et qui étaient en face de déménager pour
aller à la Villette puis après à Rungis
mais donc j'ai roulé ma brosse quand
même beaucoup dans la restauration
vous avez su voilà que vous recherchez
quelqu'un pour s'occuper de ce
restaurant d'abord quand on s'est marié
avec Annie on avait 20 ans mais quand
même déjà à l'époque nous avions comme
objectif de monter notre propre affaire
donc figurez-vous que c'est marié avec
un contrat de séparation de bien elle
avait gardé les gants de toilettes les
torchons et des serviettes et moi rien à
on se disait si on monte une affaire
qui portera les biens de la du coup et
de la famille et puis l'autre qui
prendra les risques maintenant c'est
plus possible bien entendu tout le monde
est solidaire de tout mais enfin quand
même on avait déjà réfléchi à ça et
quand on a décidé de prendre cette
affaire à 38 ans et bien on s'est
interrogé sur le fait que c'était le
seul moyen pour nous de pouvoir
rééquilibrer notre vie de famille et du
coup on a cherché ce qui pouvait nous
plaire comme entreprise et puis on a
trouvé les Templiers qui marchait pas
très bien à l'époque alors qu'il y avait
un fort potentiel en développement sur
la ville nouvelle de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et donc voilà
on a ça pas été facile au début puis
petit à petit il a fait a pris son
rythme on est passé à une affaire au
vers 7 jours sur 7 avec un ticket moyen
modeste parce que on a considéré que ici
sur la ville nouvelle les gens pour
beaucoup d'entre eux arrivaient envie de
nouvelles avec à qui leur appartement
leur maison etc donc avait pas de gros
moyens donc on a fait un une carte qui
était abordable
et d'ailleurs j'invite toujours mes
confrères à faire très attention au prix
parce que quand on est situé dans une
ville nouvelle les gens arrivent et
c'est encore le cas aujourd'hui vous
savez que le développement des grandes
entreprises qui sont arrivées à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines je parle de
Renault Technocentre je parle de l'ADN
je parle de plein d'autres grandes
entreprises et bien ce sont souvent des
gens qui arrivent et qui ont besoin de
se loger qui souvent font l'acquisition
de leur maison de leur appartement donc
il faut faire attention au fait que ces
gens ont envie de sortir mais pour
autant n'ont pas beaucoup d'argent donc
voilà on est très attentif à faire des
tickets moyens les plus serrées
possibles ce qui veut pas dire que c'est
gratuit bien entendu si on a aussi nous
une quinzaine de personnes ici on a un
loyer
donc on est très attentif à faire en
sorte que la pérennisation de notre
entreprise ne soit pas perturbé par des
à-coups dus à des mauvaises visées sur
les prix donc on reste à des prix très
accessibles qu'est-ce que la conclusion
de ces 20 ans ici quasi
vous les résumer en un mot je vais vous
dire la conclusion c'est que nous nous
sommes bien intégrés à la ville nouvelle
la crainte que nous avions Annie et moi
lorsque nous sommes arrivés nous venus
de Viroflay
quasiment né moi ma mère il y avait un
commerce donc nous étions vraiment des
vire au plaisir et lorsque nous sommes
arrivés à 50 ans de divine on s'est des
villes nouvelles ouh là là
qu'est-ce qu'on va s'y faire des amis
est-ce que et bien oui tout ça a très
bien marché et finalement je rends
d'ailleurs hommage aux autorités de
cette ville qui ont su donner une âme à
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et finalement
nous avons fait en sorte que le
restaurant Les Templiers fasse partie de
cette âme de la vie de nouvelle et
croyez-moi au bout de 20 ans de faire
partir intégrante de la société
constituée par cette ville nouvelle de
saint-quentin-en-y c'est une très bonne
chose et nous nous en réjouissons chaque
jour avec Annie oui c'est à la fois
voilà vous avez réussi en gardant l'âme
de ce lieu évidemment à vous intégrer
voilà dans ce qui est une ville nouvelle
dans l'âme d'une vie nouvelle tout à
fait et la preuve qui est la plus
flagrante c'est que tout le monde se
croise ici et bon vous savez comment est
organisé le tissu les politiques de la
ville nouvelle de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines il y a toute
la représentation politique qui est là
toute la représentation sociale qui est
là aussi et bien ici nous avons cette
science inouïe tout le monde se croiser
il y a des jours où vraiment et on nous
avons des gens très à gauche d'autres
plutôt à droite qui se croisent ici et
qui entretiennent d'excellentes
relations humaines et croyez moi ça
c'est important pour pour le
restaurateur que je suis merci
infiniment jaune avec voilà on se
connaît un tout petit on vous connaît un
tout petit peu plus à travers ces
quelques propos merci beaucoup merci à
vous mon cher Patrice